hello reject nation it's Greg Elvis here
and a John over here we're gonna watch
the trailer today for Jackie Chan's old
man Chan the four will have an inch and
the four not excited ready for my Martin
Campbell starring Pierce Brosnan yeah we
were just talking about Jackie Chan yeah
cogn amble on Twitter
hey we're gonna do a patron today shout
out at the end of this video for James
Deegan so Stiga Nader if you're watching
keep a lookout
anyway let's watch 90,000 pounds for the
names of owners don't care about me and
Richard and please find out the names of
the Ballmer's I work for the government
not terrorists
I used to work for them I don't know
moszer
[Music]
[Music]
whoa [ __ ] yeah man Dan's the chair away
for all of us Deb is every step of the
way open it
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
yes thank you do you oh oh man check and
Jackie Chan take it accept killed dude
dude dude Oh
so many thoughts the other day we were
at Collider and as a guy goes a lot
Patrick betray I'm blog like it can't
keep runnin ages PJ Campbell on Twitter
yeah and him and I really bonded the
other day because I grew up on old
school Jackie Chan Hong Kong cinema more
than just rumble in the Bronx and super
cop like we were talking about wheels on
meals fearless hyena the original legend
Erica master and Dragons forever it was
such a good talk of such a delight to
speak with him and one thing we brought
up is how Jackie Chan I thought we
thought that he could go into a great
dramatic path and how when he did the
Karate Kid that he was the best part of
that movie he should he had great
dramatic chops even in an American song
because usually the times when he gets
great romantic recognition isn't some
Hong Kong cinema so I've been wanting to
see him I take on a much darker role in
an American film yeah and this is
exactly yeah I had no idea about this
film until today and yeah this is the
trailer driver like Jerry James movie
yeah and then to see that oh this is a
lot along the line to what I've been
hoping he would be doing because I'm
like he's older now he can't be doing
like fun stick Jackie Chan doing comedy
stuff as much anymore this seems like
the right direction for him yeah
especially now I mean especially now
that we're in the age of like older guy
action film romantic yeah oh man Shannon
and bringing into I mean the thing about
seeing Jackie Chan and movie like this
is you immediately get the elevated like
you know Jackie Chan knows his [ __ ] when
it comes to action bars and some of
these action scenes I mean I'm sure he's
got more sundews now but it still looks
like he's doing the action and yeah
that's super exciting yeah I mean he's
playing like a significantly darker
rolling out boy this is a good guy who's
going down a
leave dad path like he's doing bad
things just to get his revenge it's more
than just a straight-up I thought it was
going to turn to straight-up revenge
thriller all they wants our names to the
people who killed his daughter so in the
Bombers and so he's causing harm to
these like government officials in order
just to get the names it's all antihero
kind of territory you're dealing with
here yeah it almost reminds me a little
little hints of like a Korean thriller
in the way that it man like a good man
push too far and now he's gonna go to
some defray of death to get what he
wants and so I'm curious to see how dark
this enzyme and it looks like it could
be pretty darn any literally gritty it
looks like he's given a really strong
performance and Martin Campbell has
delved dilt gentle his delve into this
territory before he Marty camel's right
to the edges tomorrow miniseries any
threat to the movie with Mel Gibson so
in that that's all a revenge story hitch
of tomorrow that head start on darkness
that danger tomorrow yeah sing Edge of
Darkness yeah hey did the Edge of
Darkness miniseries in the movie I like
the film actually and you know it don't
like Casino Royale he's done like these
dark action thrillers before work to
Pierce Brosnan and Goldeneye so this
seems like this could be a really good
thriller for sure this seems like this
could be the one to Jackie Chan's
filmography of late hasn't seemed to a
brought up very many hits and very
either financially or critically really
and it looks like it could have all the
ingredients plus I mean it's for me it's
cool to see Pierce Brosnan back in the
game and I'll there like with his real
ex and yeah he's all your rich accent
exactly I'm Pierce Rosen in he's right
next to me right now
Alicia James Bond James Bond hi John my
Irish isn't great at 9 under giant we do
more blonde
James x bond James Bond it's like a
vodka martini no sir yeah I mean one of
most excited for is that if this film
does turn out good either critically or
financially this could be a turning
point in Jackie Chan's career yeah
because the guys like it at sixties now
and you know when he came on to the
scene in America we start getting really
popular he was already like even mid
forties by that time so make sense that
he
because like the 90s he was big in early
2000 but he hasn't been popular like an
American cinema for quite a while now
like everyone knows who Jackie Chan is
but he hasn't had like a huge like
worthwhile hit this film was a hit this
could be like the turning point born it
is take on more serious action roles he
could fight Liam Neeson an identity
biggest take it oh yeah and then like
the foreigner could go all over the
Warner down under the foreigner Tokyo
trip like there's so many possibilities
Chan versus bond weird reasons behind
what what yeah that's exciting to me and
I have blond I mean I think about the
Pierce Brosnan gets to be a little bit
better because in this trailer he's
mostly seems like he's resisting doing
much of anything yeah so I hope that you
know Pierce can be pretty pretty sweet
in his own right so well here we go here
we go foreigners man foreigners I'm all
for foreigners and I hope the eye of the
tiger gets played somewhere in here
hopeful the ethanol dude
Jackie can't get now join the
Expendables dude it's about time they
can bring some humor to the expendable
alright a rejects what do you think of
the foreigner trailer are you excited or
he's excited as we are are you are you
are you now
nostalgia subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification Bell John is dat
John Humphrey on Twitter and Instagram
social media manager of blunt house and
also James deagan's Jimbo sunny buddy
James Steve has been a longtime follower
of this channel is the go-to follower
over at our patreon as well Stiga nadir
I want you to know that that's a new
name
Stiga nadir yeah what a Stiga nadir
means is that's when he farts and it's a
stink bomb necessarily but the stink
bomb is not an actual stink bomb it's
his farts that's a Stiga nadir me so if
you fart in the room you can go you just
got teenagers so it's just a synonym for
essentially I'm not actually well
congratulations
I'm sure that that many preteens around
the world are going to be excited to use
your name and it's
patronization patron of the day